our next guests aren't your typical drew
gooders they made headlines when they
spent an entire weekend picking up dog
doo doo
in 20 degree weather on the streets of
hoboken new jersey and we've all been
there out on a stroll and you look down
and someone forgot to clean up after
their dog and well if this has ever been
you
you're gonna freak out at what these
drew girders did to clean up the
sidewalks in their neighborhood just
take a look
so this is just one bag
please welcome luis perez and naomi
nyavez
[Applause]
i mean why do you do what you do
i mean pun intended yeah right
ross would love that
so um we own a pet care service called
love and harness in hoboken new jersey
um we walk about five to ten dogs at a
time
and back in february we had a really bad
snowstorm
so we decided to take initiative in our
own hands and a few weeks later in march
we uh
we went to the streets and we started
picking up some of the dog droppings
that were left behind and we spent about
six hours on a saturday and six hours on
a sunday so 12 combined during both days
and we picked about
uh 900 bags of dog droppings between
both days yes i'm hoping because it was
winter they were hard
and
cold
there's nothing like a nice wet summer
dog
i know because i have dogs and i foster
dogs
and i've had dogs i know gross but you
know what i also have babies and guess
what they poo too
but seriously like what
makes you do what so many people turn
away from and
won't do why are you such a good person
we we just honestly it was his idea but
it basically came down to the point that
we are always walking there we live in
hoboken we work in hoboken and it just
got to the point that everybody was
complaining and we're more problem
solvers than actual people who just sit
there and complain so we took the
initiative and we went out there
originally it was supposed to be a group
of us but you know him and i make a
great team and we went out there we just
started picking up the dog droppings and
you know it ended up causing such an
impact in the community which you know
we were really happy about
yeah you got yourselves on television i
bet everybody
didn't show up after that
good things happened to good people you
picked up 900 bags of droppings
900
900 bags yes and we actually made such
an impact that the hoboken business
alliance they contacted us via our
social media which is love on a harness
and basically they said that they
installed dogway stations
just because of what we did yes
[Applause]
we have a special message from the mayor
of hoboken new jersey ravi bala take a
look hello i'm hoboken ravi bala and
today i want to send a special message
to luis perez and naomi nieves it's sort
of a pet peeve of mine when owners don't
clean up after their dogs so the fact
that you cleaned up nearly 900 doggy
bags of poop well it's a load off my
mind and a load off our sidewalks you've
gone above and beyond your due diligence
and for that myself and the city of
hoboken we are awarding you with an
official proclamation thank you so much
luis naomi you deserve a big round of
applause
[Applause]
to give to you oh my god
so hang that on your wall maybe show it
to your friends
[Applause]
who didn't show up and say we want you
to come over and look at our official
proclamation from the mayor and that's
not all our friends that canaday pet
food want to donate 2500
worth of pet food and snacks so you can
share with your dogs that you walk in
your neighborhood oh my god that's
awesome thank you so much
thank you
this is awesome
this is amazing what would you say if
your dog goes to the bathroom and you're
hesitant to pick it up or you're being
lazy or you forgot about it yeah it's be
a good neighbor just you know um take
the initiative and don't have the
mentality of that's not mine you know
it's like it's not only you know
disgusting but it's unsafe for the
children and the elderly people in all
the communities and you know just
picking up a little bit next to you know
your dogs it's something that could just
make an impact i think they'll also step
in some at another point all right thank
you
you are what makes this so special thank
you so much for coming on can we please
stay in touch
[Music]